hi welcome to omixlogic studies in
biology medicine and ecology are
becoming increasingly more complex
many of these studies rely on huge data
sets and advanced computational methods
like machine learning define interesting
relationships between dna mutations and
cancer or protein structures that inform
vaccine design to prevent viral
infections
it's fascinating to hear about these
studies but did you know that many of
the authors share their data by making
it publicly available the majority of
them are actually required to do so
so instead of going to the lab to try
and reproduce these studies ourselves we
can just take the data analyze it and
make our own discoveries think about
this
after collecting thousands of molecular
profiles from tumors labs deposit
genomic data into a single location for
anyone to analyze you and i can find
these data sets generated in
professional labs using expensive
equipment and simply download them
now if only we had the skills and
computational resources needed to
analyze these huge data sets
well
you can
that's what this portal is really about
scientific inquiry using complex
biological data collectively we call it
omics genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics data that
describes in detail how biological
systems operate at the molecular level
in these lessons you'll find practical
tutorials quizzes exercises and coding
challenges i hope i didn't just lose you
there yes coding it can be intimidating
at first but omits logic makes it simple
the portal includes an interactive
console with code you can run directly
in your browser and a big data analysis
platform you can use to process
terabytes of data on the cloud this is
where you can learn to analyze data
using complex algorithms and even start
coding on your own in r or python
the portal is designed for people just
like you
curious minds that love to ask questions
find answers and showcase your findings
to the world
sign up is free and getting started is
quick
if you're new to this field i recommend
getting started by signing up completing
your profile and starting your journey
with two free courses
the first one is called introduction to
bioinformatics and the second one is
bytes and molecules this is where you'll
brush up on the basics to understand how
data is generated or used in various
applications
it's free and completing the course will
earn you a certificate that you can add
to your resume it'll also prepare you
for more advanced coursework case
studies sourced from impactful research
articles and mentor-guided training
programs on each of the topics you learn
about so why wait let's get started